ich rufe auf den zusatzpunkt zwei
beratung des antrags der fraktionen der
cdu/csu mit dem titel
neuer spirale beenden bürgerinnen und
bürger schnell und wirksam
entlasten und dieser tagesordnungspunkt
hat ja noch mal eine zusätzliche brisanz
bekommen durch die pressekonferenz des
bundeswirtschaftsministers zur lage auf
den gasmärkten merkt er ja zum
energiesparen aufgefordert aber implizit
steckt dann natürlich auch mit drin dass
die preise mutmaßlich weiter steigen
werden im laufe des jahres und ob dann
die bereits beschlossenen entlastungen
für bürgerinnen und bürger und für die
unternehmen die dürfen ja nicht
vergessen beim thema gas dann
tatsächlich ausreichen werden das ist
eine etwas andere frage jetzt also hier
der antrag der unions fraktion was die
regierung gegen die inflation vorliegt
wird dem ernst der lage nicht gerecht
schreibt sie und es spricht dazu als
erste rednerin die frühere
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
guten morgen frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen unser
leben wird teurer
lebensmittel energie mobilität die
allgemeine inflation liegt auf
rekordniveau
so hoch wie seit 50 jahren nicht mehr
bei und 8 prozent und in lebenswichtigen
bereichen sind die preise dermaßen
gestiegen zb für nahrungsmittel plus elf
prozent für energie fast 40 prozent
angestiegen und das macht den
bürgerinnen und bürgern sorge aber es
macht auch unseren unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern sorge den investitionen
produktionen die werden gestoppt und den
bürgern bleibt von ihrem einkommen und
der rente weniger übrig laut schufa
werden anschaffungen die werden
geschoben die nachfrage nach kriens
krediten steigt enorm und die quittung
die kommt erst noch zum beispiel am ende
des jahres wenn die abrechnung zur
strom- und heizkosten ins haus kommen
und hält diese inflation länger wird der
kaufkraftverlust dramatisch sein bei
einer inflation von jährlich acht
prozent beträgt dann das nach nur neun
jahren 50 prozent das heißt man verliert
in etwa zehn jahren die hälfte der
kaufkraft und der start der verdient mit
der ist inflations gewinner je
steigenden inflation punkt nimmt der
bundesfinanzminister zehn milliarden
euro mehr ein und was passiert mit
unseren arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern durch die kalte
progression zahlen sie in diesem jahr 13
einhalb milliarden euro zu viel an
lohnsteuer und da sollte man meinen das
sei alarm genug für die bundesregierung
um sofort zu handeln sofort
gegenzusteuern aber es ist bei der ampel
regierung wie in vielen anderen
bereichen auch mit großer betroffenheit
wird der zustand beschrieben und dann
passierte lange nichts
und statt die kalte progression jetzt zu
fassen lässt sich der
bundesfinanzminister zeit bis zum
nächsten jahr aber die kalte progression
ist eine heimliche steuererhöhungen und
wir fordern die kalte progression
anzupassen rückwirkend zum ersten ersten
dieses jahres das spüren die leute und
geldbeutel das ist jetzt gefragt und
dazu braucht man keine konzertierten
aktion und auch keine überlegungen und
auch keine studien das kann man jetzt
machen um jetzt die bürger zu entlasten
und jetzt ist offensichtlich
im übrigen darf man auch rentner bei der
energie pauschale nicht vergessen oder
junge eltern und wir müssen mit der
stromsteuer runter zumindest auch den
mindestmaß der europäisch ist und es
braucht im übrigen eine bundesregierung
die schlichtweg handelt statt nur
zustände beschreibt oder stückwerk
betreibt also eines nämlich ihnen sagen
jedenfalls bekennt man diese art von
inflation nicht mit einem befristeten
tank rabatt der nicht bei den bürgern
ankommt oder einem neuen euro ticket für
drei monate und wenn wir uns mal diesen
tank rabatt anschauen da haben sie doch
als bundesregierung erwartungen geweckt
die sie gar nicht einhalten können sie
sind plötzlich so überrascht wo sind die
drei milliarden euro hin das zeigt doch
eines nur das sie zuvor überhaupt nicht
überprüft haben zuvor sich überhaupt
nicht die analyse angeschaut haben der
preisgestaltung der preisstruktur
mineralölmarkt und jetzt sind die drei
milliarden euro steuergelder irgendwie
weg und es darf nicht noch einmal
passieren sagen wir sehr klar folgen sie
unserem vorschlag das bundeskartellamt
muss den markt effektiv überwachen
können die mineralölunternehmen sollten
wesentliche preisbestandteile an die
markttransparenzstelle melden und
dadurch kann die transparenz stelle
unabhängig bewerten ob eine energie
steuersenkung oder andere entlastungen
auch bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ankommen und da will ich eines noch sehr
deutlich sagen scholz hat im wahlkampf
noch versprochen einen industriestrom
preis von 4 cent pro kilowattstunde wo
ist er denn eigentlich dieser industrie
strompreis wer liegt jetzt im schnitt
wenn man ihn rechnen würde war etwa
zwölf selbst oder das die energie
pauschale erst im september ausgezahlt
werden soll oder wo ist das
zuschussprogramm dass sie für april für
die unternehmen die energieintensiv sind
und gebäude sind dass sie eine
entlastung bekommen wo ist dieses
zuschussprogramm sollte im april kommen
und stattdessen wird jetzt eine studie
angekündigt die im herbst an die arbeit
auf einem 15 monate eines kann man sehr
klar festhalten wir sind jetzt bei einer
belastungsprobe und diese ampel
regierung hat zwar für jede farbe
irgendetwas was sie anbietet aber keinen
wurf der gemeinsam ein sofortprogramm
für wirtschaft und beschäftigte ist
deshalb sagen wir sehr klar zaudern sie
nicht sondern handeln sie jetzt
die frühere landwirtschaftsministerin
und jetzige wirtschaftspolitische
sprecherin der cdu/csu-fraktion hier im
deutschen bundestag hat den antrag ihrer
fraktion teuer spirale entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger
erläutert ersten gegenrede von michael
schrodi im finanzpolitischen sprecher
der spd fraktion auf
den weg gebracht 30 milliarden insgesamt
an entlastungen bis frau klöckner wenn
sie mal die steuerschätzung lesen würden
da würde drinstehen dass vieles von dem
was an mehreinnahmen des staates da sind
über diese pakete wieder rückerstattet
wird jetzt schon 30 milliarden
mehreinnahmen
das aber gezielt die bei mila zeitung
hat heute für milliarden deutsche erhöht
sich im juli das nettogehalt mit vier
millionen deutsche erhöht sich im juli
das nettogehalt mit milliardenschweren
maßnahmen um es dann nochmal in deutlich
zu sagen 30 milliarden insgesamt die
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages gehört
dazu rückwirkend da aber nimmer
pauschbetrag der kinderbonus 100 euro
wird jetzt unter 10 uhr erste teile der
maßnahme ab jetzt wirken und spürbar
auch die inflations preise jetzt für die
bürgerin bürger abfedern werden das
haben wir auf den weg gebracht man das
rentenalter
zum ersten zum zweiten ihre
kommunikation zum thema inflation von
glöckner es ist doch richtig dass die
ursache für die gestiegene energiepreise
für fossile energie preise der krieg in
der ukraine ist übrigens die hätte
geholfen wenn sie nicht auf der bremse
gestanden wenn jahrzehntelang fast schon
bei dem ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
da sehr geholfen
angebotspreise zu senken und es sind die
störung der lieferketten in der pandemie
das sagen alle ökonomen das sagt der
bundespräsident die originale beides
liegt nicht in der verantwortung der
bundesregierung sie aber suggerieren sie
behaupten sogar fälschlicherweise auch
auf ihren social media kanälen übrigens
genau mit demselben bild wie die afg
fraktion ihre fake news verbreitet zur
inflation diese bundesregierung habe
einen teil 1 teil schuld an der
inflation das ist populismus das ist
unanständig das ist falsch und völlig
unangemessen in dieser situation
beigetragen
wir haben das schon aufgehört nicht alle
wohlstandsverluste werden wir
ausgleichen können die frage ist wer
kann sich wohlstandsverluste leisten
wenn wir zum beispiel wissen dass 20
prozent der deutschen haushalte über
kein vermögen besitzen und jede
zusätzliche belastung belastung für
kleine mittlere einkommen nur schwer zu
verkraften sind das deutsche institut
für wirtschaftsforschung hat deswegen
klar gesagt
haushalte mit kleinen einkommen werden
weitaus höher belastet einen größeren
anteil ihres haushaltseinkommens geht
für die höheren energie- und
nahrungsmittelpreise jetzt darauf müssen
sie zahlen muss sie zusätzlich ausgeben
mehr als beispielsweise zehn prozent
einkommensstärksten haushalt die
bundesregierung ganz gezielt diejenigen
haushalte entlastet die es jetzt hart
trifft die kleinen mittleren einkommen
ich habe schon erwähnt den
grundfreibetrag die energiepreis
pauschale wirkt auch so weil sie höhere
einkommen weniger stark zu gute kommt
als den kleinen mittleren einkommen also
gezielte maßnahmen die genau die stärken
die wir stärken müssen das ist der
richtige antwort auf diese krise ganz
anders verhält es sich mit ihrem
vorschlag den sie es auch unterbreiten
zur kalten progression ist ernst der
deutschen wirtschaft rechnet vor ein
jahreseinkommen von 25.000 euro wieder
entlastet mit 213 euro ein
jahreseinkommen mit 80.000 euro also und
darüber das sind auch wir
bundestagsabgeordneten würden damit
entlastet 64 72 euro das heißt die hohen
einkommen stark entlasten und nur ein
drittel kommt bei den kleinen einkommen
an die einkommen die unter dem
grundfreibetrag liegen wir kommen gar
nichts und das 15 milliarden euro teure
ich überlasse es mal den bürgerinnen
bürgern zu urteilen ob das das richtige
instrument ist in dieser situation wir
müssen kleine mittleren einkommen lassen
und nicht an der spitze and last nicht
die bundestagsabgeordneten brauchen mehr
geld in der tasche solltest du auch die
kleinen und dafür werden weiterhin
starken
und gut ist am schluss dass
bundeskanzler olaf scholz jetzt ganz
klar gesagt hat wir brauchen eine
konzertierte aktion am vierten juli wir
haben eine große herausforderung nicht
nur mit der inflation nicht nur mit dem
krieg in der ukraine sondern auch mit
der pandemie beispielsweise aber die
systeme inflation und wie wir damit
umgehen wird das thema zu einem großen
treffen von regierung von tarifparteien
der deutschen bundesbank weil wir alle
kräfte bündeln wollen und bündelt werden
um wirtschaftlich gut und sozialgerechte
die herausforderungen zukommen der
bundeskanzler hat es gesagt wir werden
niemanden alleine lassen und wir werden
alle versuche ich diese krise zu bringen
und das wird die aufgabe unserer appell
koalitions zeit und das werden wir auf
den weg bringen vielen dank
sagt michael schrodi der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion in der debatte über den
antrag der unionsfraktion teuer spirale
beenden entlastungen für bürgerinnen und
bürger und dazu redet jetzt aus der fdp
fraktion deren finanzpolitischer
sprecher kai gottschalk die regen her
pausenlos tatsächlich umstellen weil das
war ja schon grandiose
geschichtsvergessenheit herz rudi ich
habe auch an die cdu eigentlich zu
adressieren wieso heißt das eigentlich
teuer spiele der richtige titel ich tat
das war redaktionellen fehler heißt euro
spirale und da haben sie genauso
mitgemacht die inflation vernehmlich
2009 schon an mit billionen von euro
retten für die südstaaten meine damen
und herren sie lügen hier die damen und
herren die taschen und die röcke voll
rasiert und die inflation ist dadurch
bedingt qualitäts theorie ich habe es
mehrmals schon gesagt wenn zu viel geld
auf dem markt ist dann werden waren
zunächst mal teurer und natürlich ich
sag's mal ganz bitter ihn kommt der
ukraine kriegt da wahrscheinlich kann
schon recht und diese lügengeschichten
hier aufzutauchen es ist keine fossile
inflation es ist auch nicht der ukraine
krieg ursächlich am meisten ist ihre
pakete energiepolitik meine damen und
herren
schauen sie nach polen schauen sie nach
österreich wie haben die gleichen
wettbewerbsbedingungen dort ist der
spritpreis und bis zu 40 oder 50
eurocent teuer meine damen und herren
das sind die 40 50 eurocent die diese
damen und herren für andere projekte
gerne ausgeben und das ist der punkt und
den haben sie hier eben ziemlich
geschichtsvergessen
ausgelassen herrscht ja da kommen wir
auch zu anderen dingen im übrigen wird
die ganze inflations misere ja noch viel
deutlicher auf den punkt gebracht indem
der tagesspiegel ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis der präsidentin sagt dass
rumeiern der ezb sei dran schuld es geht
um achtung ohren gespitzt fachausdruck
schuldentragfähigkeit fragmentierung der
arbeiten sie ja schon dran wie können
wir wieder italien die defizit staaten
hätten meine damen und herren die angst
vor einer neuen zweiten eurokrise geht
um meine damen und herren das ist die
bittere realität
sie wissen genau so gut wie wir dass die
höheren zinsen einige süd länder wie
spanien italien aber auch frankreich
mittlerweile der club med nicht mehr
fragen können an den rande der insolvenz
bringen und dabei italien und
griechenland ehrlich sind ohne die
steuergelder von ihnen meine damen und
herren wären diese länder schon pleite
bono geht es um die
schuldentragfähigkeit oder eigentlich
das problem dass diese party und
deutsche weiter staaten des südens
unsere niedrigen zinsen haben wollten
aber eben weiter über ihre verklebten
lebens verhältnisse gelebt haben das ist
die realität deswegen haben wir jetzt
diese krise meine damen und herren herr
gottschalk gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerkungen aus den
reihen der cdu csu fraktion aber
selbstverständlich
sie haben das wort
gerne da bin ich anders als einige der
parteien mir ich weiß sie haben es ja
verstehen nicht
können sie
ich glaube das 1 2 ist
ja wunderbar sie haben davon gesprochen
dass einige südländer aufgrund der
zinsentwicklung jetzt schon am rande der
insolvenz sind ja das ist natürlich
nicht richtig weil es gibt situationen
der staatsverschuldung italien ist mit
rund 78 integration verschuldet das
heißt das dauert sieben acht jahre bis
sich das aktuelle zinsniveau tatsächlich
niederschlägt und auch zu echten
verschuldungsproblem führt woher nehmen
sie dann die erkenntnis dass jetzt schon
am rande der insolvenz sind wo ich gebe
da auch gerne eine antwort ist freut ich
danke für die frage also italien wir
hatten mal maastricht wird hier
eigentlich glaube das haben sie den
menschen auch gesagt und ihr
bundeskanzler helmut kohl dass der euro
renten eingeführt wird und genauso hart
wie die d-mark und die deutschen wollen
wir schützen indem wir entsprechende
kriterien 60 prozent kriterium
staatsverschuldung im bid festlegen mit
wenn ich ihnen sage dass italien
mittlerweile auf die 160 zugeht an den
zinsmärkten italien schon mittlerweile
für staatsanleihen mehr als drei prozent
zahlen ich muss ihnen das data bei
dieser staatsverschuldung nicht erklären
griechenland jenseits der 200 es auch
als ich in frankreich war mir dort der
französische finanzminister noch erklärt
wir werden jetzt alles tun ja unter 90
prozent zu kommen pustekuchen wir sind
jetzt bei über 100 prozent und makro hat
0 geleistet als zweitgrößte oder
drittgrößte volkswirtschaft und
nürnberger spanien punkten ist es
genauso grausam ich glaube wenn wir die
fragmentierung und die hilfs politik der
ezb und das ist ein eigentor von über
zwei billionen schulden titeln die
aufgekauft worden zur staatsfinanzierung
da kann keiner sagen was er will dann
wären diese staaten schon gleitet denn
wer würde den griechenland italien ein
ernstes jetzt noch geld geben bei dieser
situation würde es satt machen dann ist
italien und leitet den wm rekord
finanzierung deswegen ja auch schon 2009
die verrenkungen von herrn draghi
whatever it takes also wir sind uns
hoffentlich einig wenn da wenn die ezb
zu lasten von ihnen dort oben nicht mehr
als zwei millionen staatstitel auf
gekauft hätte dann wäre morgen schon aus
um italien hätte wahrscheinlich über 10%
und deswegen haben wir ja auch mal über
375 milliarden gesprochen wir haben
griechenland ein schuldenschnitt gegeben
haben uns auch darüber über den
berühmten haircut unterhalten also ich
bitte sie von der union ganz inständig
wir gehören zusammen kommen sie auf den
pfad der tugend zurück lassen sie uns
doch zusammen währungspolitisch vernunft
machen wir machen die menschen da
draußen also kehren sie zurück zu dem
was sie und ludwig erhard mal stark
gemacht hat da würde ich mich freuen
[Applaus]
ja also tatsächlich sie haben ich habe
es ja eben ausgeführt mit der
nullzinspolitik und das war schon ein
teil dieser staatsrettung meine damen
und herren dort draußen auf den tribünen
mit ihren ersparnissen in ihren renten
schon mal die staaten des südens
finanziert und nun kommt eben die
endstufe einer jeden währung viele der
älteren haben es erlebt eine
galoppierende inflation auf der anderen
seite belastet nämlich diese hohe
inflation nicht nur die menschen die
geringe einkommen haben auch der
normalverdiener ich zitiere aus dem
handelsblatt mit der erlaubnis der
präsident bis zu
672 euro haben diese menschen weniger
und dann kommt noch und da sperren sie
sich ja auch machen sich endlich mit die
kalte progression das heißt das kennen
sie wenn sie ihr weihnachtsgeld gucken
bekommen dann schauen sie mal sehr
verwirrt auf den lohnzetteln sagen da
kommt ja wenig an dann nämlich ja
vielleicht mehr urlaub das ist genau die
kalte progression die in unserem
steuertarif festgelegt ist auch da
entlasten sie viel zu wenig und haben
mich immer hier der lüge und der
falschaussage bezichtigt sie haben dort
belogen sie entlasten die menschen nicht
um den vollen betrag der kalten
progression
also auch hier kein umdenken zu erkennen
die schulden koalition macht weiter so
nach gutdünken verteilt sie ein paar
almosen meine damen und herren die
finden sie dass bei 1000 2000 euro
vielleicht nachzahlung dass strom
zusammen der sie dann 300 euro die sie
auch noch versteuern müssen viel spaß
als großes geschenk dieser regierung
verkaufen meine damen und herren das ist
nichts wir als ard sagen dass das thema
inflation kommt schon seit mehr als fünf
jahren seit wir hier im bundestag sind
es ist zeit umzudenken zeit umzudenken
für die union um meine damen und herren
glauben sie bitte nicht diesen
geschichten die ihnen hier im auf die
pisten sind vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen andreas odrich
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der massive preisanstieg den
wir erleben der geht weiter heizöl war
im mai
2022 fast doppelt so teuer als ein jahr
zuvor und auch bei den industrie
abnehmen sind die preise förmlich in die
höhe geschossen wenn man sich das bei
den kraftwerken anschaut dann sind die
preise für erdgas im mai 200 41,2
prozent höher gewesen als ein jahr zuvor
das sind dramatisch hohe zahlen und das
zeigt einmal mehr dass wir raus müssen
aus diesen fossilen energien dass wir
raus müssen endlich und weg müssen von
dem gas von putin von dem öl und damit
eine ganze reihe von problemen lösen den
klima die klimaschutz frage gehen wären
wir gehen endlich und unabhängig von
vladimir putin zu werden und wir
bekämpfen die inflation das passiert
nämlich nicht mit irgendwelchen
taschenspielertricks sondern damit dass
man die ursache angeht und die liegt
genau an dieser stelle
gleichzeitig ist klar dass sich diese
preise auf lebensmittel durchschlagen
die preise sind auch da dramatisch in
die höhe gegangen 11 prozent plus im mai
2022 und wenn man sich diese zahlen
anguckt dieser abstrakt aber konkret
bedeutet das dass bei den tafeln
mittlerweile aufnahmestopps vor ort
verhängt werden weil nicht mehr genug da
ist um es zu verteilen oder jeder
sechste sagt dass er mahlzeiten aus
lässt oder sie mahlzeiten aus lässt weil
das geld am ende des monats nicht mehr
reicht das ist eine dramatische lage und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir schon
entlastungs paket beschlossen haben 30
milliarden es wurde gesagt und in den
nächsten tagen wird das ganz konkret bei
sehr vielen menschen ankommen erster
juli 200 200 euro einmalzahlung für die
menschen in der grundsicherung die
werden dann dort auf dem konto sein der
die eeg-umlage die abschaffung wird ab
dem ersten juli dann auch ziehen und wir
haben das neue euro ticket das haben sie
alles alle verfolgt das wirkt schon aber
wir wissen alle
wir wissen alle dass diese krise nicht
kurzfristig enden wird das ist nicht das
ende der geschichte der
diktator vladimir putin wird ohne
wimpernzucken und die autos so weit
meine damen und herren so weit der
bundeswirtschaftsminister zur lage auf
den gasmärkten und sie sehen wir sind
jetzt auch im sogenannten linearen
fernsehen wieder live im deutschen
bundestag hier wird gerade heftig
diskutiert über einen antrag der
unionsfraktionen der den titel trägt
teuer spirale beenden bürgerinnen und
bürger schnell und wirksam entlasten es
gibt allerlei vorwürfe die
bundesregierung und die koalition täten
zu wenig die koalition verweist darauf
dass die entlassungs pakete ja bereits
beschlossen worden sind und
beispielsweise
erster juli jede bürgerin jeder bürger
das auch spüren wird rund jetzt sind wir
bei der frage angekommen wer wie
mitverantwortlich ist für die derzeitige
inflation und was dagegen getan werden
kann dazu ist im moment am rednerpult
andreas dresch für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
um zu verstehen um zu verstehen um zu
verstehen wie sehr unterbewertet der
regelsatz ist muss man sich angucken wie
er berechnet wird wir haben die anhebung
zum ersten januar dieses jahres mit
einem bezugszeitraum der vom 30 vom
ersten juli 2020 bis zum 30 juni 2021
geht damals gab es keine inflation
damals waren die preise völlig andere
und deswegen sind die regelsätze im
moment per definition unterbewertet das
ist und deswegen haben wir ganz konkret
vorgeschlagen eine inflations und krisen
reserven in höhe von zehn prozent des
regelsatzes auf den weg zu bringen und
das brauchten wir dauerhaft 50 euro plus
während das im moment ungefähr die krise
wird morgen nicht enden die krise wird
weitergehen genauso müssen wir die
sozialpolitik behandeln wir müssen in
dauerhafte entlastung rein die menschen
brauchen unterstützung jetzt jeden monat
regelmäßig und vor allem verlässlich
und ganz genau so haben wir natürlich
die menschen im blick mit den kleinen
und mittleren einkommen die jeden tag
arbeiten gehen und wo am ende ist
trotzdem nicht reicht die familie zu
ernähren und genauso mit dieser
perspektive gehen wir auch in die
debatte wenn wir über einkommensteuer
sprechen und wenn wir über die frage
reden wie man wie man an der stelle
entlastungen organisieren könnte und das
ist doch völlig klar dass sie frau
klöckner sie haben die kalte progression
angesprochen dass sie frau klöckner
keine entlastung brauchen die brauchen
sie nicht die brauche ich nicht die
brauchen wir alle hier nicht die
brauchen auch nicht die fußball-profis
die brauchen auch nicht die
konzernchefin die alle brauchen diese
entlastung nicht aber wer sie braucht
das intim den ganz kleinen einkommen das
sind die die wir adressieren müssen und
sie mit der gießkanne überall drüber zu
gehen das ist genau das problem an der
politik die sie machen konzentrieren sie
sich auf die menschen die es brauchen
auf die menschen die nicht genug haben
um zu leben das ist das was wir
adressieren lassen sie uns politik
machen mit einer perspektive auf die die
es jetzt nötig haben den hartz4 satz
anheben für die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen entlastung organisiert und
nicht die ganze breite und die ganz oben
im blick haben wie sie das hier
vorgetragen haben dankeschön
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke janine wissler und die ist
bekanntermaßen ja parteivorsitzende der
linken und stellt sich am wochenende zur
wiederwahl das übertragen wir ihnen
natürlich umfänglich und deswegen muss
ich diesen kleinen programmhinweis an
dieser stelle schnell mal loswerden
bezahlen sollen die energiekosten
steigen die nahrungsmittel sind seit
letztem jahr um elf prozent teurer
geworden einige wie speiseöle sogar um
40 prozent das trifft menschen mit
geringem einkommen am stärksten und
deshalb muss ihnen auch am meisten
geholfen werden was diese
preissteigerung für menschen im alltag
bedeuten schildern viele menschen offen
und mutig unter der überschrift ich bin
armut betroffen im internet und dabei
geht es nicht darum ob man sich alle
paar jahre mal ein wochenendurlaub
leisten kann nein für viele geht es um
die frage ob sie mahlzeiten aus lassen
und ob sie im winter noch ihre wohnung
werden heizen können eine junge mutter
fragt überall findet man spart chips da
gerade alles teurer wird aber was macht
man wenn man diese neuen spar tipps
bereits seit jahren durch zieht wo
sollen wir noch sparen wenn wir schon
überall kürzer treten und das
entlastungspaket der ampel war eben bei
weitem nicht ausreichen und das war eben
auch nicht zielgerichtet menschen mit
hohem einkommen wurden doch deutlich
stärker entlastet als menschen die
wirklich wir brauchen studierende und
rentnerinnen und rentner die sind auch
völlig außen vor geblieben im gegensatz
zu ministerinnen und minister die die
entlastung bekommen und das muss
geändert werden
sozialleistungen müssen kurz was sich um
200 euro angehoben werden mindestens die
kindergrundsicherung muss eingeführt
werden zur erinnerung der hartz iv
regelsatz wurde in diesem jahr um drei
euro erhöht für erwachsene bei kindern
war es nur zwei euro und jetzt gibt es
auch noch einige jobcenter die wegen des
neuen euro tickets auch noch geld für
die schülerbeförderung zurückverlangen
von familien die hartz iv beziehen weil
sie sagen es sei eine ungerechtfertigte
bereicherung das ist doch wirklich eine
sauerei meine damen und herren
nötig sind nötig sind zudem staatliche
preiskontrollen damit überhöhte preise
nicht immer weiter subventioniert werden
in einigen ländern werden die preise für
strom öl und gas und zwar vom einkauf
über die produktion bis zum verkauf
staatlich kontrolliert damit spekulanten
sich eben nicht zu lasten der
verbraucherinnen verbraucher bereichern
können frankreich hat den anstieg der
energiepreise beim staatlichen
stromkonzern auf 4 prozent gedeckelt im
gleichen zeitraum stiegen die preise in
deutschland 23 prozent meine damen und
herren wir brauchen dringend eine
staatliche energiepreis kontrolle
statt lassen haben wir christian lindner
der mit seinem krank rabatt anschaulich
vorgemacht hat wie es nicht funktioniert
und mittlerweile haben doch alle gemerkt
was viele vorher gesagt haben herr
lindner der tank rabatt lang nämlich zu
erheblichen teilen gar nicht bei den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
sondern er fließt als extragewinn in die
taschen der mineralölkonzerne dass das
auch noch mit steuermitteln finanziert
wird meine damen und herren das ist doch
eine skandalöse umverteilung wo ist denn
da ihrer haushaltsdisziplin die sonst
die energiekonzerne machen wie will die
weit über dem durchschnitt der
vergangenen jahre liegen und das tun sie
doch nicht weil sie ein besseres produkt
oder bessere leistungen anbieten nein
sondern einzig und allein durch höhere
preise aber die konzerne und ihre
aktionäre die mine finanzminister linda
offenbar nicht wenn er von fünf jahren
der knappheit spricht meine damen und
herren diese krisen erträge diese über
gewinne die müssen durch eine über
gewinn steuer abgeschöpft werden und
solche steuern werden zumal auch schon
erhoben zum beispiel in italien
die eu kommission hat im märz
vorgeschlagen außerordentliche gewinne
vorübergehend zu besteuern diese
zusätzlichen einnahmen die brauchen wir
doch um die menschen zu erlassen die
wirklich brauchen nämlich die größte
berliner und die geringverdiener meine
damen und herren ich würde auch deutlich
machen dass die menschen im globalen
süden ganz besonders leiden unter der
teuerung und den steigenden
nahrungsmittelpreisen nach schätzungen
des welternährungsprogramm ist die zahl
der akut vom hunger gefährdeten in
einigen teilen der welt um mehr als 60
prozent gestiegen und das hat letzter
satz sollte sich der bundeskanzler
beim g 7 gipfel am wochenende dafür
einsetzen für hungerbekämpfung und für
ein verbot von
nahrungsmittelspekulationen weil essen
gehört auf den teller und nicht an die
börse
janine wissler vorsitzende der partei
die linke hier mit ihrem beitrag zum
antrag der unionsfraktion zu weiteren
entlastungen für bürgerinnen und bürger
markus herbrand ist der nächste redner
aus der fdp-fraktion
30 märz die versorgungs und sicherheit
vor allem bei energie wie für engpässe
und die steigende rezessionsangst
alarmieren die politik der
industriemotor stockt gewaltig die
brandgefahr von russland wir haben sie
alle unterschätzt und jetzt brennt es
lichterloh bei den energiepreisen den
nahrungsmitteln produktionskosten hinzu
kommen auch weitere schwierigkeiten wie
beispielsweise der fachkräftemangel umso
mehr ist es jetzt zeit für eine sehr
überlegte politik und das gilt ganz
besonders für die finanzpolitik die die
folgen der inflation ab zu federn
versucht
deswegen ein hinweis wenig mehr als
ordnungspolitiker nicht müde werde zu
wiederholen es ist das mandat der
europäischen zentralbank die inflation
mit hilfe der geldpolitik zu bekämpfen
der bundestag kann und da es sich nur
auf maßnahmen der abfederung der
auswirkungen einer solchen inflation
beständen beschränken und das hat er
auch voller entschlossenheit in ersten
schritten getan die ampel koalition hat
in wenigen monaten massive entlastungen
auf den weg gebracht wie wahrscheinlich
keine regierung zuvor in so kurzer zeit
die diversen entlastungs pakete 1 und 2
vieles ist schon genannt worden corona
steuer hilfe gesetzt ihre abschaffung
der eeg-umlage kinderbonus energiepreis
pauschale absenkung der energie steuern
auf kraftstoffe dabei sind also auch
sehr strukturell entlastende maßnahmen
wie dauerhaft und nicht nur einmalig
wirken wie beispielsweise die erhöhung
des grundfreibetrages bei der
einkommenssteuer oder auch die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage man
unterstellt die eeg-umlage bliebe
ansonsten konstant setzt die ampel damit
für den rest dieser legislaturperiode
rund 67 milliarden euro für nachhaltige
vor allem auch sozial ausgewogen und
zukunftsweisende entlastungen um diese
massnahmen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren wirken ganz gezielt gegen die
inflation
geschätzte kollegin kollegen der union
augenscheinlich haben sie vergessen dass
sie vor nur drei sitzungswochen schon
einen antrag zur inflation gestellt
haben der sich noch im parlamentarischen
verfahren befindet offenbar gilt die
hälfte der damaligen forderungen die er
noch gar nicht abschließend beraten sind
so jetzt nicht mehr jedenfalls tauchen
sie nicht mehr auf oder die forderungen
der beiden anträge gelten
additiv dann wird es noch
unglaubwürdiger
das sehr geehrte kolleginnen und belegt
ist es kamen politik für schnelle klicks
in den sozialen netzwerken damit haben
sie sich gegen eine seriöse
finanzpolitik entschieden die jetzt so
wichtig ist nicht ein
überbietungswettbewerb neuer konsumtive
ausgaben wird uns den weg aus der
inflation weisen sondern gezielte
wachstumspolitik in die notwendigen
transformationsprozesse in unserer
gesellschaft haushaltsdisziplin und
subventionsabbau an stattdessen erleben
wir eine aufgeschreckte cdu csu die sich
mit ihren eigenen forderungen selber
überholt das ist schade und eher ernsten
situation meines erachtens nicht
angemessen meine damen und herren
ganz besonders in zeiten solcher krisen
darf man jetzt auf gar keinen fall die
nerven verlieren die politik muss
vorausschauen überlegt aber auch ehrlich
sein und da gehört es zur wahrheit dass
jetzt alle bürgerinnen und bürger und
ganz besonders auch der staat mit den
vorhandenen finanzmitteln umsichtig
kalkulieren muss auch dieser antrag wie
zuvor schon ihr erster antrag zur
inflation verwendet keinen moment auf
den wichtigen gedanken woher das geld
für die vielen kleinteiligen forderungen
überhaupt kommen soll kein wort zu einer
soliden haushaltspolitik
damit die belastungen nicht noch höher
werden das zeugt von einem sehr geringen
verantwortungsbewusstsein für den
haushalt unseres landes sorgt für
falsche versprechungen bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und ist auch
wenig staatstraße antrag ist sehr
verkürzt nimmt nur einen begrenzten
ausschnitt der problematik in den blick
und ist deshalb auch nicht glaubwürdig
wir werden diesen antrag deshalb
ablehnen
markus herbrand für die fdp-fraktion wo
ihr finanzpolitischer sprecher ist und
jetzt kommt auch einer der jetzt auch
schon wieder eine ganze weile im neuen
amt ist nämlich jens spahn in der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unions-fraktion
entlasten was sie gemacht haben ist 300
euro pauschale für fast jeden nur für
rentnerinnen und rentner nicht für
eltern in elternzeit nicht für
studentinnen und studenten nicht was sie
gemacht haben ist einen neuen euro
ticket das super sporting event dieser
wochen übrigens in der sommerzeit für
drei monate da geht es eher um urlaub
als um arbeit die pendler die zum mit
dem auto zur arbeit fahren bei uns im
ländlichen raum daheim diejenigen die
nach dem urlaub wieder mit bahn und bus
fahren müssen die haben davon gar nichts
sie haben mit der gießkanne entlastet
die handlich selbst nach frieden in der
koalition gemacht den menschen geholfen
haben sie mit viel geld nicht das muss
man nach wenigen tagen schon
konstatieren und wenn sie gerade gesagt
haben umsichtig vorsichtig kommunizieren
in den letzten tagen wir haben viele
vorschläge aus jeder der
regierungsfraktionen mindestens drei
gehört wie man richtig entlastet gestern
abend koalitionsausschuss alle erwarten
dass endlich die entlastung kommt in
diesen zeiten höchster inflation das ist
zusätzliche maßnahmen gibt übrigens das
ist die vorletzte sitzungswoche vor der
sommerpause wenn sie den menschen noch
entlastungen geben wollen zeitnah dann
müssen sie jetzt in dieser woche
eigentlich gesetzgeberisch damit
beginnen anstatt hier reden darüber zu
halten was man angeblich alles erreicht
hat und das war gießkanne bei keim ist
richtig was angekommen hätten wir uns
erwartet dass wir diese woche mal
konkrete vorschläge bekommen wie sie in
der breite in der tiefe entlasten wollen
über stromsteuer über kalte progression
sie reden nur viele vorschläge viel
durcheinander wir machen einen konkreten
vorschlag so wie es nötig ist um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten
und deswegen will ich auch zu aktuellen
lage was sagen auch die energiepreise
sind ein teil dieser inflation und der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat gerade
bezogen auf die gasversorgung in
deutschland und das hat auswirkungen auf
die inflation und auch auf die preise
die alarmstufe gas festgestellt ich
würde sagen dass das grundsätzlich
natürlich richtig ist wenn die lage nach
einschätzung der bundesregierung so ist
dass das notwendig ist wir haben die
energie sicherheitsgesetze teilweise
auch mitgetragen weil wir in einer
krisenzeit ungeahnter ungeahnten
ausmaßes sind mit dem überfall putins
auf die ukraine und in der frage der
energieversorgung und deswegen gibt es
grundsätzlich ja in solch einer
krisenzeit auch ein vertrauensvorschuss
für und in die regierung aber wir haben
auch fragen
robert habeck hatte noch am 31 märz
gesagt wir sind auf alles was putin tun
könnte gut vorbereitet noch vor sechs
wochen hat er gesagt haben uns auch
vorbereitet auf alles nun ist übers
wochenende plötzlich erlauben nun heißt
es der winter kommt das war vor sechs
wochen auch schon bekannt wir haben
schon die frage was ist jetzt passiert
dass wir vor sechs wochen vorbereitet
waren und es jetzt nicht sind wir haben
fragen warum sie nicht früher die
kohlekraftwerke wir haben fragen warum
sie nicht früher die kohlekraftwerke
mehr genutzt haben um die gaskraftwerke
runterzufahren wir haben das schon im
märz gefordert hätten sie im märz im
märz haben sie alle noch gelacht als ich
hier das gefordert habe hätten sie im
märz damit geworden wir an die
gasspeicher heute voller
wir haben die frage warum sie nicht
früher begonnen haben auch den vorschlag
haben wir schon im märz gemacht anreize
zu setzen für die industrie für die
privaten haushalte gas zu sparen nicht
frieren per gesetz sondern über anreize
eben den anreiz zu setzen die gas
einzusparen wäre der richtige weg wir
haben die frage warum nicht früher wir
haben die frage warum sie in einer
solchen anlage notlage krisenlage
bestimmte maßnahmen schon von vornherein
ausschließen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat heute
morgen
die alarmanlage gas angekündigt und
gleichzeitig sagt jürgen trittin aber
erdgasförderung in der nordsee 60
milliarden kubikmeter gas das kommt auf
gar keinen fall in frage das brauchen
wir nicht sie sagen notlage aber nur den
streck betrieb wir reden hier gar nicht
über fünf oder neun jahre gehen wir
einfach nur über drei vier monate streck
betrieb kernkraftwerke jetzt etwas
weniger nutzen im winter mehr nutzen das
ist technisch einfach möglich sie sagen
notlage richtigerweise sie schließen
aber von vornherein bestimmte maßnahmen
aus das passt nicht zusammen
soll ich ihnen was sagen ja kurz ist ist
mir egal was eon und rwe davon hält weil
eon und rwe alles nur betrachten aus
ihrer unternehmerischen brille natürlich
wollen die das nicht weil es ihre
unternehmensplanungen stört mir ist es
egal was die unternehmen wollen ich will
das was richtig ist für deutschland für
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
und deswegen geht es darum den
kernkraftwerken auch bei dem track
betrieb zu wählen
und ja ich habe auch noch eine frage
ich habe noch eine frage zum umgang
miteinander ich habe gerade gesagt wir
sind bereit verantwortung zu übernehmen
haben sie übrigens in der gesetzgebung
an verschiedenen stellen hiermit
übernommen gerade auch bei der frage der
energiesicherheit
aber dann finde ich es schon zumindest
mal eine frage wert warum parallel fast
zu dieser debatte im deutschen bundestag
journalisten in einer pressekonferenz
informiert werden der deutsche bundestag
der hier parallel takt und sich mit
fragen auch im bereich von wirtschaft
und energie beschäftigt nicht informiert
wird sondern das ganze dann im fernsehen
verfolgen darf sorry das passt aber auch
nicht zusammen sie waren es grüne und
fdp die letzten jahre manchmal
vielleicht sogar zu recht immer wieder
gesagt haben hier im deutschen bundestag
spielt die musik hier müssen die
debatten stattfinden und ich habe die
erwartung dass wir ja alle die
kommunikation über institut alles gut
alles richtig beeindruckend aber ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir öfter auch
hier mal informiert werden dass der
minister sich auch öfter hier mal der
debatte stellt er hat sich hier noch
keiner debatte gestellt zu inflation und
er hat sich hier auch in dieser frage
keine watte gestellt er regiert per
pressekonferenz und das ist gegenüber
dem deutschen bundestag nicht angemessen
jens spahn stellvertretende vorsitzende
der unionsfraktion in der debatte zum
antrag der unionsfraktionen teuer
spirale beenden jetzt gibt es erstmal
ermahnende worte von yvonne markt was
die klingen spd fraktion war gar keinem
angebot war nur die begrüßung und der
aufruf für melanie welling aus der spd
fraktion
hätte jetzt also hier die ganz großen
antworten wenn ich mir jetzt aber diesen
antrag anschaue und mir mal den titel
anschaue dann ist eigentlich recht
schnell zu erkennen dass von diesem
antrag eigentlich keine seriöse
auseinandersetzung mit diesem komplexen
thema zu erwarten ist da haben die reise
zweier spirale beenden ich nehme an sie
meinen damit die inflation das heißt die
intention ihres antrags ist es wohl die
inflation zu stoppen dann sprechen sie
aber auch weiter von entlasten also ist
der inhalt dann wohl doch eher darauf
ausgerichtet die auswirkungen
abzumildern und doch nicht die inflation
zu beenden
wer es ernst meint
ich meine wer es ernst meint erlaubt
sich bei dem thema inflation eigentlich
ausreichend tiefgang insbesondere in
zeiten von multipler globale krisen und
ich hatte eigentlich erwartet dass sie
in ihrer analyse vielleicht erstmal der
frage nachgehen was eigentlich die
treiber der inflation sind ich kannte
ihn auch nicht mit vollkommene
sicherheit sagen die haben alle eine
diffuse vorstellungen davon
wissenschaftlich gesehen lassen sich
aber eben die konkreten ursachen für
inflation seltenst eindeutig
identifizieren manchmal eben noch nicht
mal druck wird die faktoren sind aber so
können wir vermuten wahrscheinlich
zinspolitik lieferengpässe ukraine krieg
steigende energiepreise würden da jetzt
alle ursachen gleichzeitig oder ist da
eine inflationstreiber vielleicht ein
katalysator für den anderen
nichtsdestotrotz die auswirkungen davon
die erlebe ich jeden tag wenn ich immer
im wahlkreis unterwegs bin da ist der
baustoffhändler aus crumstadt der
spezieller intensiver engpässe von
baumaterial und telefoniert überall in
der welt umher um die ware zusammen zu
bekommen da ist die bäckerei aus
gernsheim die produziert die backwaren
wegen der gestiegenen benzinpreise jetzt
noch auf lücke so darf zwar weniger
lebensmittel entsorgt werden müssen aber
es bleibt dann eben auch nichts mehr
übrig um es an tafeln und co zu spenden
und in meinem elterlichen
handwerksbetrieb müssen jetzt
fahrtkostenpauschale erhoben werden
damit sich die anfahrt zu den baustellen
nicht zum minusgeschäft entwickelt wir
als ampelkoalition sehen all diese fälle
unternehmen die auswirkungen für die
menschen die dahinter stecken sehr sehr
ernst und deshalb haben wir auch bereits
zahlreiche entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht
wenn ich mir jetzt aber diesen so
seitigen unionsantrag anschaue stelle
ich mir ehrlich gesagt eine frage ist
der antrag jetzt einfach unseriös
populistisch und zeigt viel zu wenig
respekt vor der komplexität der
aktuellen situation oder zeigt der spaß
nahmen antrag von gerade mal zwei seiten
dass die regierung eigentlich alles
richtig macht und die union verzweifelt
versucht auf zwei seiten karte
zusammenzukratzen die ihn angeblich
nutzen
so oder so verantwortungsvolle
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit sieht in
meinen augen anders aus falls ihr antrag
tatsächlich ernst gemeint sein sollte
für diese komplexe situation möchte ich
noch darauf hinweisen dass die
aufgezählten maßnahmen keinesfalls die
inflation starten so wie sie in dem
titel ist aber eigentlich anpreisen
möchten sondern eben im besten fall nur
deren auswirkungen abmildern können
politisch würde ich sagen muss uns dann
aber fragen für wen wir diese
auswirkungen denn eigentlich ab mitteln
wollen da schaue ich in ihren antrag ich
würde jetzt persönlich sagen politisch
bewertet er nicht für die von ihnen
angesprochenen eigenheimbesitzer mit
photovoltaikanlagen sondern eben eher
für haushalte die bank auf ihre nächste
strom oder nebenkostenabrechnung waren
die in ihrer mietwohnung sitzen und
nicht wissen wie sie diese nächsten
rechnungen bezahlen sollen einer
ernsthaften verteilungsgerechtigkeit
wird der antrag deshalb nicht gerecht
und im übrigen als eine seiten
bemerkungen für ihre analyse es ist
ökonomisch betrachtet auch gefährlich
geld anstellen zu pumpen die es
eigentlich benötigen das wäre nämlich
ein weiterer inflationstreiber die
abmilderung der auswirkungen auf
haushalte und aktive strukturelle
inflationsbekämpfung muss zielgenau
besonnen und durchdacht sein
glücklicherweise bringt die ampel
regierung genau die richtigen köpfe mit
um das umzusetzen genau das machen wir
auch schon und damit machen wir weiter
dankeschön
melanie welling weist natürlich dafür
dass aus ihrer sicht der antrag der
unionsfraktion nicht so richtig
zielführend sein könnte bernd schattner
ist in das der nächste redner aus der
afg fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir werden ärmer werden dies ist ein
zitat unseres vize-kanzlers robert
habeck die man der einheit zum wohle des
deutschen volkes geleistet hat für
deutschland aber wie er selbst bestätigt
in die arme ein zitat von unserem
finanzminister lindner auf einer
industrie veranstaltung diese woche
lautet der bürger muss den wohlstand der
arbeiten damit die politik den wohlstand
verteilen kann das ist reinstes
sozialistische politik einer einst
liberalen partei
diese entwicklungen haben dazu geführt
dass energiepreise um 38,3 prozent und
lebensmittelpreise um 11,1 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr gestiegen sind
allein im dezember 2021 betrugen die
steuereinnahmen
100 ls milliarden an den fiskus und
trotzdem diskutiert unser vizekanzler
und die spd über eine über gewinn steuer
mit dieser vertreiben ja dann noch die
letzten unternehmer aus deutschland ob
inflation explodierende energiekosten
oder eine falsche zinspolitik seit
jahren waren sich die afg fraktion vor
genau der entwicklung die jetzt über uns
hereinbricht
mittlerweile haben selbst die grünen
erkannt dass ich auf einem irrweg sind
und wollen zurück zur kohle verstromen
genau wie die fdp mittlerweile die
kernenergie erhalten
herr minister habe wir wollen im winter
nicht bei kerzenlicht sitzen am
lagerfeuer kochen daher sollten sie die
von daher auf die bundestagsfraktionen
vorliegenden vorschläge welche die cdu
mit dem hier vorliegenden anträgen
übrigens hervorragend kopiert aufgreifen
wir fordern bereits seit jahren die
kohle und kernenergie als
grundlastversorgung zu erhalten
habe ich kein problem damit im übrigen
muss man der union einst lassen ihre
anträge sind mittlerweile fast
deckungsgleich mit denen die wir als af
die fraktionen schon vor wochen monaten
gestellt haben vielleicht sollten sie
mal in sich gehen sicher
kooperationsverbot überdenken und
einfach gute anträge da hat gegenüber
sie betreiben mittlerweile eine relativ
gute oppositionsarbeit indem sie anträge
im original von uns übernehmen unser
debatte bringen dies zeigt dass sie doch
ein guter koalitionspartner wären aber
uns doch bietet diese fach politische
richtung überlassen sollten und
vielleicht sollten sie gerade an dieser
stelle nochmal über ein
kooperationsverbot nachdenken in
thüringen könnten sie bereits seit
jahren gemeinsam mit uns regieren mit
der aktuellen politik dieser sogenannten
fortschritts koalition steigen nicht nur
die energiekosten ins unermessliche auch
lebensmittel werden für viele zum
luxusgut dann heißt es nicht nur frieren
gegen zu tun sondern auch noch hungern
gegen putin diese regierung ist nicht
diese regierung ist nicht in der lage
deutschland mit annehmbaren preisen für
energie und lebensmitteln zu versorgen
sie als regierung haben in dieser
position auf ganzer linie versagt
und der nächste redner in der debatte
ist markus kurth bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen was wir gegenwärtig in der
preisentwicklung sehen insgesamt ist
tatsächlich einmalig für die
nachkriegszeit der bundesrepublik
deutschland das wird jetzt auch nicht zu
ende sein sondern wir haben wie das
finanzminister christian lindner richtig
eingeschätzt hat nach meiner meinung
auch noch in den nächsten jahren
erhebliche verwerfungen an den märkten
und folgen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger die für millionen tatsächlich
existenzielle ängste bedeuten und in
dieser situation in dieser wirklich
epischen krise in dieser situation haben
die bürgerinnen und bürger der
bundesrepublik deutschland eine
ernsthafte und seriöse debatte verdient
und dem wird der antrag der union und
auch die rede von frau klöckner und was
wir von herrn spahn gehört haben leider
überhaupt nicht im ansatz gerecht
und das fängt
das fängt eine seriöse debatte fängt aus
meiner sicht damit an dass man sich auch
mal mit den ursachen im rückblick
beschäftigt wer hat uns denn in diese
abhängigkeit des kreml faschismus
gebracht wer hat denn jahre
jahrzehntelang die energiewende
blockiert ausgesessen und hintertrieben
das waren doch sie von der union und es
hilft jetzt natürlich nix hätte hätte
fahrradkette aber ich finde zu einer
ehrlichen reflektion der situation
gehört dass man das nicht unter den
teppich kehrt und verschweigt
und zu einer seriösen debatte gehört
auch sich einfach mal die fakten
anzugucken bezüglich der
entlastungspaket dieser regierung diese
30 milliarden ja gerade jüngst ist eine
studie des instituts für makroökonomie
und konjunkturforschung der
böckler-stiftung
herausgekommen und das sind ja jetzt
nicht unbedingt die aller engsten
freunde vielleicht aller parteien die in
dieser regierung sind aber sie sagen
sehr klar in mehreren fallbeispielen
dass wir relativ gezielt familien mit
einem geringen einkommen entlastet haben
sie haben ein modellbeispiel das denn
ich hier mal ein paar mit zwei kindern
paar mit zwei kindern geringer verdienst
also in der spanne 2000 bis 2600 euro
netto dort werden die preissteigerungen
der letzten monate zumindest durch die
entlastungs paket zu 90 prozent
ausgeglichen und bei ein paar mit
haushalt mit zwei personen ohne kinder
ist der ausgleich bei den
geringverdienern immerhin zu 78 prozent
das finde ich kann sich durchaus sehen
lassen
und wenn diese haushalte vielleicht auch
dann ja auto nochmal etwas öfter stehen
lassen sofern sie denn eine pnv angebot
haben das besser sein könnte wenn die
union in den letzten jahren nicht die
verkehrsminister gestellt hätte wenn sie
dann das neun euro ticket nutzen kann
man nach den berechnungen des emk sogar
von 100 prozent ausgleich in diesen
bereich sprechen es ist natürlich ein
kompromiss gewesen wir wissen selbst
dass es eine lehrstelle gibt eine
besondere das sind die rentnerinnen und
rentner bei der energiepreis pauschale
aber man kann davon ausgehen seien sie
gewiss wenn wir die perspektive in den
blick nehmen mit weiteren gezielten
entlastung dann werden wir die
rentnerinnen und rentner auch nicht
vergessen sie hingegen wollen mit der
bekämpfung wie sie das nennen der kalten
progression
diejenigen noch unter eine warme
geldbuße stellen wie mich die das
überhaupt nicht nötig haben und das
werden wir uns in zukunft nicht leisten
können und darauf werden wir auch achten
darauf werden wir achten als
ampelkoalition dass wir mit den mitteln
des staates verantwortlich umgehen und
gezielt entlasten und das unterscheidet
uns ganz wesentlich und das ist auch der
unterschied mit blick auf seriosität in
den politischen angeboten vielen dank
sagt markus kurth wohl einheiten der
rentenexperten in der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen in dieser debatte in der
es um weitere entlastungen für
bürgerinnen und bürger geht zumindest so
wie sich die unionsfraktion das
vorstellt zum thema jetzt maximilian
mordhorst aus der fdp-fraktion
prioritär weil es zeigt dass bei allem
guten willen in der sozialpolitik bei
allem guten willen bei umverteilung das
thema wirtschaftspolitik doch am ende
entscheidend dafür ist ob wir es
schaffen dass der soziale ausgleich in
diesem land hergestellt bleibt und
deswegen müssen wir dringend nicht die
inflation beenden das können wir nicht
aber die rahmenbedingungen so zu setzen
dass der staat nicht noch weiter die
inflation treibt wir müssen ausgaben
kritisch auf den prüfstand stellen und
wir müssen für solide und verlässliche
haushalts und finanzpolitik sorgen und
wir müssen auch
wir müssen auch dafür sorgen dass wir
keine falschen anreize setzen sie sagen
das ja selbst sie wollen wenn man ihn
antrag liest auch mehr geld umverteilen
aber wenn man mal beispielsweise mit dem
baugewerbe spricht die brauchen alles
aber nicht mehr geld die brauchen die
haben zu wenig personal die haben zu
wenig material und sie wollen weniger
bürokratie wir sollten die überhitzten
märkte mit dem staat nicht noch weiter
anheizen wir sollten eher die ursachen
bekämpfen und liebe union warum haben
die zu wenig personal weil sie sich 16
jahre lang an vernünftigen fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz verwehrt haben weil
sie die ausbildung und grund genug in
den ländern stärken warum haben wir zu
wenig material weil sie nicht dazu
beigetragen haben dass die
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit concealer
reduziert wird und die bilder kann man
alle sehen jeder kennt sie im hafen von
shanghai wir müssen mehr diversifizieren
auch in unserer wirtschafts und
handelspolitik und nicht mehr auf
einzelne staaten setzen wir müssen mehr
auch auf die werte schauen und darauf
dass so etwas wie eine no go wird police
policy eben ein handelshemmnis sein kann
und ja wir müssen auch die chip neu auf
den tisch legen und neue bündnisse
schließen für eine moderne und
verlässliche handelspolitik damit solche
lieferschwierigkeiten nicht mehr
vorkommt
freut mich dass die grünen klatschen
und wir müssen lieber entlasten statt
weitere ausgaben zu erhöhen ich sage das
auch für die freien demokraten ganz klar
was in dieser zeit gefährlich ist ist
das reden über eine neue toxische
neidsteuer wie sie jetzt einige auf den
weg bringen wollen die auch jens spahn
ins spiel gebracht hat das so wird es
nicht funktionieren in der finanzpolitik
wenn wir dafür sorgen wollen dass die
inflation nicht noch weiter antreibt und
das ist auch keine sozialpolitik wenn
man nur davon spricht dass es fußballer
und sozialhilfeempfänger gibt das ist
doch nicht nur deutschland dazwischen
gibt es eine breite mitte in der
gesellschaft und auch die müssen wir
viel mehr unserer politik schauen weil
es nicht ausreicht nur von fußball von
fußballspielern und
sozialhilfeempfängern zu sprechen sie
spielen die gruppen damit gegeneinander
aus und müssen die mitte der
gesellschaft stärken und nicht weiter
gegeneinander ausspielen
wir werden deshalb auch die zeitenwende
in verschiedene bereiche der politik
übertragen
die schuldenbremse bleibt garantiert und
das nicht nur weil wir sie politisch
richtig finden sondern weil sie ein
gebot der verfassung ist wir können
nichts besseres tun um der inflation
einhalt zu gebieten als uns an die
schuldenbremse halten und wir können
nichts besseres tun in der
energiepolitik als darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir es in zukunft
schaffen die energiepreise zu
diversifizieren und auch im notfall neu
zu denken zb über das thema kernenergie
und da geht es nicht nur um
atomkraftwerke wie es einige sagen da
geht es auch darum dass bestimmte
forschungsbereiche jahren politisch
gewollt brach liegen wir müssen dann neu
denken und auch neu überlegen ich glaube
in einer notsituation ist es richtig
pragmatisch zu sein und ich freue mich
sehr darüber dass wir diesen diskurs
jetzt auch als gesellschaft suchen und
dass wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen können
dass der treiber der inflation in dem
wir mehr für freiheits energien sorgen
ich hoffe da klatschte auf den nicht
mehr beendet wird sondern dass wir auch
dafür sorgen dass er eine vernünftige
haushalts und finanzpolitik der
inflation einen rahmen setzte sie
beendet oder ihr einhalt gebietet und
die wirtschaft wieder ordentlich in gang
kommt vielen dank
und der nächste redner debatte johannes
steiniger cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen haben soll der
verschieden stellen gehört einkaufen
wird für viele familien zum stresstest
die inflation ist das größte
alltagsprobleme der menschen in
deutschland und man muss sich fragen was
macht die ampel sie haben bisher in
ihren entlastungs paketen er stückwerk
vorgelegt der bundeskanzler spricht hier
gestern in einer regierungserklärung und
erwähnt den begriff inflation kein
einziges mal und gestern treffen sich
die koalitionsspitzen der ampel wir sind
alle
überrascht und freuen uns dass da
irgendwas passiert aber nein heute
morgen lese ich in den in den
nachrichten die wichtigen themen wurden
ausgeklammert das thema inflation haben
sie nicht besprochen sie haben keine
beschlüsse gefasst und so geht's nicht
und deswegen ist es gut deswegen ist es
gut dass wir diesen antrag hier heute
ein bringen dass sie sich ihrer
verantwortung stellen müssen und den
menschen in deutschland sagen müssen wie
wollen sie die inflation bekämpfen und
wie wollen sie auch die folgen abfedern
und es sind auf der einen seite die
folgen die abgefedert werden müssen auf
der anderen seite aber auch die ursachen
wir machen hier ganz konkrete vorschläge
wie man die folgen abfedern kann wir
weisen auf das thema kalte progression
hin und es ist eine heimliche
steuererhöhung wir müssen dafür einen
ausgleich führen mal nur eine zahl
dessen 11,5 milliarden euro die durch
die inflation jetzt mehr reinkommen über
die kalte progression schaffen sie hier
abhilfe sorgen sie dafür und herr motto
ist ich schwöre dass ich ja gern dass
sie auch meiner meinung sind aber
ehrlich gesagt die fdp hat an dieser
stelle schlecht den koalitionsvertrag
ausgehandelt der begriff kalte
progression kommt im koalitionsvertrag
nicht vor im übrigen anders als bei den
großen koalition in der vergangenheit
wir haben es mit den sozialdemokraten
hinbekommen das aus zu haben außer
fanden sie haben es nicht hingekriegt
und wir müssen auch schauen wir müssen
auch schauen die wirtschaftspolitik
wurde angesprochen die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
industrie ist nicht gottgegeben wir
haben das gestern in den nachrichten
auch aus dem saarland gehört deswegen
müssen wir etwas tun bei den
strompreisen nicht nur für die
privathaushalte sondern auch für die
industriestrompreise machen sie hier was
verlängern sie den spitzenausgleich es
ist dringend notwendig aber wir müssen
auch die ursachen angehen und jetzt wird
ja gesagt wir können hier als deutscher
bundestag nichts tun das ist natürlich
nicht richtig wir sind
haushaltsgesetzgeber und eins ist doch
klar verschuldung verschuldung
verschuldung führt zu einer höheren
inflation uns wird in der vergangenheit
immer gesagt ja die schwarze null sei
ein fetisch wieso haltet ihr immer an
der schwarzen null fest wir die grünen
haben uns im wahlkampf erklärt montblanc
dann monetary theorie also sprich nach
dem motto immer mehr schulden aufnehmen
der in der heutigen zeit keine schulden
aufnimmt der wehr irgendwie blöd jetzt
sehen wir die hohe verschuldung trägt
dazu bei dass wir eine hohe inflation in
deutschland deswegen kommen sie zurück
zu einer soliden haushalts- und
finanzpolitik
und natürlich müssen wir uns auch die
angebotsseite anschauen das thema
energie und ich würde mir schon wünschen
dass frei der future wieder auf die
straße geht und demonstriert aber
diesmal für die verlängerung der
kernenergie man es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir jetzt die dreckige kohle weiter
zusätzlich verbrennen und einfach die
drei atomkraftwerke
auslaufen lassen am ende des tages das
kann doch nicht sein deshalb darf in so
eine existenz existenziellen tage keine
denkverbote geben meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
bundesregierung bereitet dieses land
nicht auf das vor was im zweiten
halbjahr auf uns zukommt in den nächsten
sechs monaten
wage ich die prognose kommen alle krisen
der letzten zehn jahre zurück die euro
krise die finanzkrise die
flüchtlingskrise die korona krise und
jetzt auch die inflations krise sie
bereiten die bevölkerung nicht auf diese
krisen vor dass die jetzt zusammen
kommen setzen sich endlich dran die
bürger erwarten antworten von ihnen
herzlichen dank
johannes steiniger aus der
unionsfraktion und natürlich darf in
dieser debatte auch die frage ob es
laufzeitverlängerungen geben soll für
die drei letzten kernkraftwerke in
deutschland nicht fehlen mal hören was
andreas mehltretter dazu sagt aus der
spd fraktion
meine damen und herren der antrag der
union ist tatsächlich eine klassische
mogelpackung auf dem antrag steht teuer
spirale durchbrechen im antrag sind aber
kaum maßnahmen drin die die installation
tatsächlich dämpfen könnten wir alle
kennen die zahlen dieses jahr erwartet
die europäische zentralbank eine
jährliche inflationsrate von 6,8 prozent
diese inflation ist für uns alle spürbar
für viele ist sie aber nicht nur spürbar
viele können sich die stark gestiegenen
preise schlicht nicht leisten
natürlich müssen wir diese menschen
entlassen das haben wir schon getan und
das werden wir auch mit zusätzlichen
maßnahmen tun vor allem dort wo menschen
von den kostensteigerungen überfordert
sind wir tun aber auch das was sie
versprechen aber mit ihrem antrag nicht
halten wir müssen die inflation
abdämpfen und das heißt wir müssen daran
wo die preisanstiege tatsächlich
herkommen eine hauptursache dabei sind
die energiepreise schon im winter sind
sich gestiegen und seit dem krieg in der
ukraine sind sie steil nach oben
gegangen mit den steigenden
energiepreisen zahlen wir jetzt dafür
dass wir zu lange in der abhängigkeit
von fossilen energieträgern geblieben
sind wir zahlen dafür dass wir die
erneuerbaren energien einfach nicht
schnell genug ausgebaut haben
schon jetzt ist strom aus wind und sonne
viel günstiger als strom aus gas und
kohle und auch als atomstrom und während
die preise für fossile energieträger
gerade durch die decke gehen ist
abzusehen dass die kosten bei
erneuerbaren energien weiter sinken
werden es ist und bleibt daher richtig
die energiewende voranzutreiben weil wir
unsere klimaziele erreichen müssen weil
wir nur so unabhängig von fossilen
energieträgern werden und weil wir nur
so die preisspirale durchbrechen können
die preise sind auch deswegen so hoch
weil gas öl und kohle nicht so sicher
verfügbar sind wie wir immer geglaubt
habe eine laufzeit verlängerung der noch
laufenden atomkraftwerke bietet diese
sicherheit aber genauso wenig ganz im
gegenteil dazu was sie liebe union in
den in diesen tagen immer wieder
behaupten das zeigt gerade ein blick
nach frankreich
dort sind mehr als die hälfte aller
atomkraftwerke gerade wegen
sicherheitsmängeln außer betrieb das
heißt kernenergie kann die
versorgungssicherheit nicht
gewährleisten und teuer ist sie auch
noch der ausfall der französischen
atomkraftwerke hätten ganz europa die
teuren gaskraftwerke am laufen und
treibt den strompreis nach oben das sind
die fakten liebe union
um gas zu sparen und den strompreis
wieder zu drücken müssen wir jetzt
leider
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve ans netz
nehmen das ist bitter aber eben leider
notwendig wir wollen weitere anreize
setzen den gasverbrauch zu reduzieren
für die industrie sind dafür
aktionsmodelle konkreten planung und bei
den privaten haushalten schlagen wir zum
beispiel einen energiespar bonus vor
weil auch ein geringerer verbrauch
insgesamt für jeden einzelnen dem die
preise senkt
gleichzeitig tun wir alles was sinnvoll
ist um ein ausreichendes angebot an gas
sicherzustellen weil mehr angebot gibt
auch die preise wieder drückt deswegen
schaffen wir in einem rasanten tempo
anlagen der möglichkeiten für flüssiggas
und fühlen unsere speicher
meine damen und herren wenn wir über zu
hohe preise reden müssen wir auch
darüber reden wo im moment die preise
hochgetrieben werden um möglichst großen
profit aus der aktuellen situation zu
schlagen genau das ist zb bei benzin und
diesel das problem das kartellrecht
sollte hier dagegen halten können aber
diese schwert ist leider eher ein
stumpfer durch die lücken im derzeitigen
kartellrechts sind offensichtlich nicht
erst seit heute übrigens eine reform
werde auch schon unter dem letzten
wirtschaftsminister übrigens von union
fällig gewesen das holen wir jetzt nach
wir werden sektoruntersuchungen so
ausbauen dass sie konkrete
maßnahmen zur folge haben für mehr
wettbewerb und damit für niedrigere
preise wir werden die hürden für die
vorteilsabschöpfung ab entscheidend
senken und auch entflechtungen als
letztes mittel ermöglichen meine damen
und herren zur bekämpfung der inflation
gehört eine energiepolitik die den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
beschleunigt statt ihn mit unsinnigen
abstandsregeln zu verhindern und das so
gehört ein kartellrecht das günstigere
preise durch mehr wettbewerb schafft wir
brauchen keine unions mogelpackung
sondern diese konkreten maßnahmen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben und die
den preisanstieg wird die bremsen
sagt micha sagt andreas mehltretter aus
der spd-fraktion in der debatte über
weitere entlastungen von bürgerinnen und
bürgern angesichts der steigenden
inflationsraten aber auch der steigenden
lebensmittel- und energiepreise
katharina beck ist am pult für die
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen sieges
finanzpolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
kollegen liebe damen und herren ich darf
noch mal in zwei minuten ein bisschen
ordnung in die debatte bringen es gibt
drei aspekte die sehr wichtig sind das
eine ist natürlich die geldpolitik der
handel die ezb sie ist er unabhängig sie
handelte sondern das ist gut das zweite
ist die entlastung das sind auf einige
der maßnahmen die sie ja beschrieben
haben in ihrem aber viel zu kurzen
antrag wir haben über 15 maßnahmen
beschlossen ein entlastungspaket 1 und 2
über 30 milliarden nur dieses jahr 60
milliarden insgesamt und einer der mir
da gerade werden die ganze zeit die
kalte progression und die
einkommenssteuer angesprochen wird viel
zu kurz kommt schon allein wäre es toll
dass wir nur den grundfreibetrag um 363
euro angehoben haben rückwirkend zum
ersten ersten dieses jahres das wird die
menschen schon jetzt greift entlasten
besonders unten und das ist sehr sehr
tief so rainer man ganz viel besser aber
vw kling hat es so schön gesagt was ist
eigentlich mit der ursachenbekämpfung
und lieber markus wir sind ja auch nicht
nur zum abfedern da sondern auch zu den
ursachen zu bekämpfen es gibt ganz
konkrete zahlen die installation von 7,9
prozent davon ist fast die hälfte sind
die energiepreissteigerungen und dann
muss man sich noch gucken dass der ganze
rest also die energie die in den
bäckereien verbraucht es beispielsweise
und natürlich in den anderen
industriestandorten dass das auch die
preise steigert unsere
lebensmittelpreise die hängen maximal
davon ab wie die energie steigt bisschen
auch von lieferketten aber der
energiepreis steigerungs effekt auf die
teuren lebensmitteln ist gerade in
deutschland richtig richtig hoch und
deswegen müssen wir an die energie ran
und das tun mit drei sachen die
oligopolistischen marktstrukturen werden
endlich mit einem verschärften
kartellrecht angegangen denn diese haben
bisher verhindert dass es faire preise
gibt am energiemarkt zweitens die
diversifikation auch die grüne hahn in
staaten wo wir keine lust drauf haben
aber wir müssen uns auch für die
übergangstechnologie auch mit fossilen
energien das tut mir weh aber es ist so
diversifizierter aufstellen und endlich
von den 55 prozent die sie uns
hinterlassen liebe cdu und csu 55%
abhängigkeit nur von putin russland das
geht doch so nicht wir sind schon auf 35
runter und das müssen wir leider weiter
machen das werden wir weitermachen und
das dritte um sie wieder zum schluss
ausgabe der freiheits energien bürger
energien souveränen und das sind vor
allen dingen noch die günstigsten
energieformen aller zeiten ich freue
mich darauf dass wir hier endlich
losgehen und nach 16 jahren jemand
vorankommt herzlichen dank
katharina beck war die drittletzte
rednerin in dieser debatte jetzt hören
wir noch anja weisgerber aus der
unionsfraktion und
dann sehen wir weiter
viele menschen in unserem land können
nicht mehr schlafen weil sie nicht
wissen wie es weiter geht angesichts der
steigenden preise
der großteil des einkommens geht für die
miete und die nebenkosten drauf vom rest
müssen sie leben das heißt lebensmittel
kaufen versicherungen und andere
fixkosten bezahlen die mobilität des
alltags finanzieren und auch mal mit
freunden ausgehen aber das ist schwierig
angesichts der gestiegenen preise die
lebensmittelpreise ist in dem vergleich
zum vorjahr um elf prozent gestiegen der
energiepreise um 40 prozent warum
erzähle ich ihnen das weil das die
ausgangslage für viele menschen in
unserem land ist rentnerinnen und
rentner studentinnen und studenten
eltern in elternzeit
profitieren nicht von der energiepreis
pauschale ständig können kündigen sie
weitere entlastungen an liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der ampel
wann kommen die denn das sind sie den
menschen in unserem land schuldig
kündigen sie diese entlastungen nicht
nur an sondern beschließen sie diese in
dieser und in der nächsten sitzungswoche
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
herr schrodi auf unsere zwischenrufe
haben sie überhaupt nicht reagiert weil
sie darauf keine antworten haben beim
thema rentnerinnen und rentner
studentinnen und studenten haben sich
schlicht keine antworten geben sie das
doch mal zu warum haben wir die hohen
energiepreise
natürlich aufgrund der angespannten lage
am energiemarkt als folge des russischen
angriffskriegs es gibt aber immer noch
kein stimmiges gesamtkonzept der
bundesregierung keinen fahrplan keinen
konkreten fahrplan zur reduktion der
russischen gas und öl importe und zur
reduktion der abhängigkeit davon richtig
ist die gasspeicher zu befüllen richtig
ist auch weiter zu diversifizieren und
bei aus weiteren ländern gas zu
importieren wir alle müssen auch den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien massiv
vorantreiben
aber es nicht bringen zu kurz was ist
mit der kleinen wasserkraft was ist mit
der geothermie was ist mit der biomasse
jede kilowattstunde zelt und genauso
handeln sie nicht meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
und die entscheidungen werden politisch
getroffen und nicht nach sachargumenten
auf der einen seite sinniert die
regierung über einen frost erlass der
die menschen im winter staatlich
verordnet frieren lässt zum anderen
fallen die klimaanlagen erst ab 26 grad
an halten werden auch in den altenheimen
auch in den krankenhäusern und auf der
anderen seite war kann sich die grünen
minister vehement die kernkraftwerke
vorübergehend weiter zu betreiben und
sich setzen anstatt dessen auf kohle
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
ist unverantwortlich gegenüber den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern in
unserem land und es ist klimapolitischer
unsinn
dass keine missverständnisse aufkommen
das bedeutet für uns nicht dass wir
einen ausstieg aus dem ausstieg wollen
wir wollen wenig euphorie nicht erlauben
sie eine zwischenfrage vom kollegen der
grünen
peter kurth nutzen weisgerber sie haben
hat gerade von der dringenden
notwendigkeit gesprochen die
erneuerbaren energien
auszubauen von geothermie biomasse
wasserkraft vielem anderen mehr aber sie
sind ja abgeordnete aus bayern und da
würde mich mal interessieren was sie
denn davon halten dass in bayern die
restriktivsten abstandsregeln für die
mit abstand günstigste erneuerbare
energie zur stromproduktion nämlich für
die windenergie herrschen so meint muss
man mal sagen in bayern sind wir zb
spitze bei der sonnenenergie wir sind
auch spitze bei vielen anderen
erneuerbaren energien und beim thema
wind müssen sie auch mal nach baden
württemberg schauen was ist denn der
eigentliche grund der eigentliche grund
ist es die windhöffigkeit bei uns nicht
zu hoch ist und dass man im süden auch
eine höhere vergütung braucht dafür
setzen wir uns ein wie muss das auch
beschließen und muss diese höhere
vergütung auf den weg bringen und zudem
muss ich auch mal sagen haben sie sich
eigentlich mal auseinandergesetzt mit
den jüngsten beschlüssen auch die wehren
der landtagsfraktion in bayern
dort haben wir haben ausnahmen von der
10h regeln auf den weg gebracht und was
ist die reaktion von hab ich bin
eigentlich ein wortbruch mit den
ausnahmen setzt man sich gar nicht
auseinander man sagt einfach pauschal
diese abstandsregelungen die werden
pauschal in frage gestellt vom bund das
ist nicht energiewende mit den menschen
wir brauchen nämlich auch die akzeptanz
der bürgerinnen und bürger wir brauchen
auch eine höhere vergütung dass auch die
kommunen profitieren von
freiflächenanlagen von windkraftanlagen
wir brauchen die menschen sonst kann die
energiewende nicht gelingen und genauso
handeln sie nicht meine damen und herren
letztes thema tank rabatt die
kraftstoffpreise steigen
diese ist jetzt teurer als vor der
steuersenkung am ersten juni sie könnten
für mehr transparenz sorgen prüfen sie
doch mal ob die mineralölunternehmen
nicht dazu verpflichtet werden können
die wesentlichen preisbestandteile an
die markttransparenzstelle zu melden
dann wird ersichtlich ob die
steuererleichterungen wirklich auch
weitergegeben werden meine damen und
herren das hätten sie schon vor
einführung des tank rabatz machen müssen
deshalb sage ich zum schluss beenden sie
ihren dornröschenschlaf und sorgen sims
sinne der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher für mehr transparenz und für
wirkliche entlastungen für alle das
sehen sie den menschen schuldig vielen
dank
anja weisgerber aus der unionsfraktion
hat noch ein bisschen redezeit dazu
gewonnen durch die zwischenfrage von
markus kurth aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und jetzt sind wir
tatsächlich beim letzten redner hier
angekommen lennart öl aus der
spd-fraktion und danach geht es weiter
mit dem bericht des petitionsausschusses
die aktuelle inflation ist ein
ernsthaftes problem da sind wir uns mit
sicherheit alle einig was den antrag der
union betrifft sind wir es
wahrscheinlich nicht denn es beginnt ja
schon mit der ursachenanalyse
wenn friedrich merz gestern und herr
steininger heute an diesem pult ihr
behaupten die hohen staatsschulden seien
die ursache der aktuellen inflation dann
muss sich ergänzen das zu einer
nachfrage kurve auch immer eine angebots
kurve gehört und das angebot hier ganz
besonders die preise nach oben zieht es
sind die lieferketten engpässe der
rohstoffmangel des energie embargo all
das drückt die angebots kurve nach oben
das sind die wahren ursachen der
aktuellen inflation
die bundesregierung hat ja bereits zwei
umfassende entlastungspaket von einem
volumen von insgesamt 30 milliarden euro
auf den weg gebracht das ist bei ihnen
wahrscheinlich völlig vorbeigegangen und
bevor sie jetzt rufen dass die
massnahmen nicht wirken wenn eine
ernsthafte analyse der maßnahmen ist es
doch noch viel zu früh und da der
kollege sparen dem das jetzt alles nicht
schnell genug geht dem sei gesagt dass
neun euro ticket gilt ja schon zum
ersten sechs werden bereits pendlerinnen
und pendler entlastet die 50 euro für
eine monatskarte zahlen und die machen
auch keine drei monate urlaub wie erst
behauptet hat zumindest nicht in dem
paper buxheim indem er einsparen wohnt
sinnvoller wäre ist anstatt jetzt neue
maßnahmen neue wünsche zu fordern doch
erstmal die konzertierte aktion des
bundeskanzlers mit den sozialpartnern am
vierten juli abzuwarten ich bin
überzeugt dass wir bis dahin ein breites
bündnis gegen die hohe inflation mit
gezielten lösungsvorschlägen erwarten
können aber was fordern sie konkret im
antrag sie möchten rentner und
studierende in der energiepreis
pauschale mit einbeziehen das zeigt ja
dass sie von diesem instrument was sich
die regierung hergegeben hat das ja gar
nicht so schlecht finden aber viele
rentner und studierende sind ja noch
oder schon erwerbstätig und sind
erhalten die energiepreis pauschale
sowieso und werden die lasten diese
personengruppen auch gezielt über andere
maßnahmen
gleichzeitig fordern sie dann die
steuerfreiheit bei einkommensteuer und
umsatzsteuer aus der photovoltaik
welchen entlastungseffekt das jetzt
konkret bedeuten soll das erschließt
sich mir persönlich nicht es konnten sie
mir heute noch nicht erklären außer dass
die bisherigen betreiber von
photovoltaikanlagen eine zusätzliche
steuer subvention erhalten im ostpaket
wurden bereits umfassende
vergütungsanreize
photovoltaik anlagen beschlossen die
nachfrage ist hoch die auftragsbücher
der handwerker sinnvoll eine steuerliche
entlastung ist hier überhaupt nicht
zielgerichtet
zum tank rabatt der kollegin glöckner
und der kollegin weiß ja aber sei gesagt
das ergebnis zeigt dass der rabatt nicht
vollständig weitergegeben wird das
finden auch wie es schade dennoch sind
die preise gefallen zwar nur leicht aber
sie sind gefallen wie das ifo-institut
beispielsweise ermittelt hat die preise
wären ohne den tank rabatt deutlich
höheren erklären sie das den unternehmen
erklären sie das den haushalten wenn wir
da nicht gehandelt hätten aber klar ihre
aufgabe opposition ist es natürlich den
tank rabatt zu kritisieren aber umso
mehr überrascht es mich dann jedoch dass
sie mit der senkung der stromsteuer ein
eben solches instrument in ihrem antrag
fordern dabei auch nicht sicherstellen
können ob die steuer lächeln das du
weitergegeben wird
der antrag bleibt ein konkretes
maßnahmen kompott den zuschuss gefördert
wird oder eine steuersenkung aber
gleichzeitig wird auch der staats und
sparen aufgerufen und das ist unser
spruch den sie nicht erklären können
obwohl wir die wirksamkeit der
bisherigen maßnahmen auf die sparen das
konsumverhalten der haushalte und der
unternehmen noch gar nicht analysieren
können die spd fraktion daher auf
ablehnung vielen dank
sagt lehnert öl und damit endet die
debatte über den antrag der
unionsfraktion teuer spirale beenden
schnellere und wirksamere entlastungen
der bürgerinnen und bürger der antrag
wird jetzt sofort abgestimmt und sie
ahnen es ein klein wenig wirkt keine
mehrheit bekommen im plenum bestenfalls
noch die unterstützung aus den reihen
der fdp aber auch das ist ja eh nicht
immer sicher wir blicken auf den
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt sie sehen es
gerade noch nicht mal die afg stimmt für
diesen antrag sondern lehnt ihn auch mit
ab